hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles all of them are
endgame positions with white to play and
it's up to you to determine the best
continuation in each case so in this
puzzle puzzle one go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to puzzle one is Bishop to d5 with its
primary purpose to prevent this pawn
from advancing allowing that pawn to
advance would mean that this Bishop can
come back and essentially defend against
this pawns promotion so Bishop to d5
interferes with this idea after pawn
takes Bishop g5 and this pond cannot be
stopped from queening similarly if the
black King tries to track it down after
this Bishop goes to d5 the King tries to
run after it
what eventually happens is that the pot
arrives on g7 f8 is controlled f7 is
controlled and this pond once again
cannot be stopped from queening so the
key move in puzzle 1 the solution is
going to be Bishop to d5 so I'm moving
on to puzzle 2 once again white to play
go ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to this one is Bishop to h6
not even caring about the Queen because
mate on f8 is coming and there's no
successful way to defend against that it
may have been very tempting to just want
to first react to the rook takes Queen
threat by coming down to c8 but the most
direct move and the best continuation
here is Bishop to h6 with this maid
threat there isn't really a good defense
at all if let's say the rook were to
play back to defend we would just have
pawn takes Queen and maid is just around
the corner from here so the key move and
this one is Bishop to h6 that would be
the solution in the puzzle to moving out
to the third one we have once again
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best continuation for white
ok the solution to this one is to
actually take into account that white
doesn't even have to react to this pawns
advancement because there's a mating net
right around the corner starting first
which is King takes pawn and there's a
mate and 3
I'm coming about for example if the pawn
advances it's all forcing moves Knight
g5 king takes pawn rook f7 King in the
corner rook h7 and that's me personally
I was very tempted when I first saw this
position to just grab the rook and then
grab this pawn get my King to that g6
square and then try to get my Knight to
f6 but unfortunately it comes one move
too late of course if it was White's
move it'd be mate but certainly in this
position turn out to be blacks move
so really the the key move the solution
of this one is to just grab this pawn
the threat of Knight g5 rook f7 to h7 is
there's no there's no way out of that
one
so moving out to the fourth one once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white okay solution to this one is
Queen 208 its primary purpose is to try
and take over control of blacks back
rank clears this rook away from the
queening square after c8 another forcing
move we have rook takes Queen rook takes
rook and the only good block here in
this case is 90 to f8 which now runs
into rook takes Knight and in the event
of King takes rook we have 97 finishing
up very nicely with a fork
winning the Queen and the resulting
endgame however the variation is not
finished yet because the black King does
not have to take the rook if you can
instead play to that h7 Square and
that's where this h4 pawn plays a role
starting first with h5 with the idea of
watching over g6 so the knight can pivot
there once the knight is there it's
guarding h8 which would allow the rope
to play to h8 to deliver checkmate
there's no successful way to defend if
the Queen just grabs it upon Knight g6
and you'll note that there's not even a
fear of the Queen giving perpetual check
to the white king because this rook
conveniently watches over f2 and so maid
is right around the corner here
on that h8 square there is one other
possibility the Queen from this position
or from the position here for black we
don't need to do this Queen takes pawn
move but instead there is better
resistance in the way of the pawn
advancing to let's say that g5 square
essentially just clearing that g7 square
for the black King to go to and after
that move we could have pawn takes pawn
on passant and came to g7 the only move
rook f7 and whether or not the King goes
to g8 or h8 it doesn't matter the knight
will be making use of this key square g4
for example King g8 would allow Knight
to g4 with a the threat of Knight to f6
and you would actually have your pick of
what kind of mate you would want to do
from that position for example Knight f6
as soon as the King moves you could play
rook to h7 which we mate or maybe even
nicer on to g6
or excuse me g7 and that would also be
made one other slight variation is that
after this position right here after the
roof gives check on f7 the King doesn't
have to go to g8 but instead h8 again
the night plays to g4 Queen takes pawn
and now we have this sequence of moves
rook check King g8 Knight check King f8
so the king is just getting walked all
the way to this east v8 Square rook f7
check King e8 and after pawn to g7 this
pond will not be denied that g8 Square
to promote to a queen and once again
note that the rook is conveniently
keeping a close eye on that f7 Square so
that there is no black queen getting out
of hand and checking the White Queen
around so certainly a lengthy variation
is this puzzle number 4 but that was the
solution to that one moving on to the
final one once again white to move pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay the key move
the first move is root 2 H 4 and black
has two options if pawn takes rook we
just have a Megan one Queen to g6 and
that's me
if instead king takes rook that will now
run into essentially the queen really
making good use of the whole chessboard
starting first with queen h7 if the King
goes to g4 this this will run into a
very quick mate on h3 but instead if we
have the Queen blocking now we have all
forcing moves pawn takes pawn check King
g4 Queen d7 check Roe cast a block Queen
D 1 check rook has to block again and
after Queen takes rook that's me so
that's all for this video be sure to let
me know how you did on all five of these
puzzles that's all for now take care bye